millions of people around the world
depend directly on the Seas for their
food and livelihood for their well-being
and their future seafood is fundamental
for health and nutrition but also for
jobs and welfare today many factors
threaten the sustainability of world
fisheries like over-exploitation
unsustainable practices or illegal
fishing as the largest market in value
and the largest donor of development aid
the EU is a key player in the fight
against illegal fishing supporting
marine science and promoting market
transparency central to this is
increasing the capacity of communities
to control protect and trade their local
resources sustainably but U is therefore
supporting people around the globe to
better manage their fisheries and
aquaculture securing food
reducing poverty and delivering real
growth that is sustainable and inclusive
by helping partners technically and
financially the EU enables international
changemakers to inspire others like
training mauritania Nguyen
in better fish processing techniques or
supporting people in Madagascar to
better target stock the market
much-sought-after mangrove crabs while
also protecting their habitat or
co-financing an ambitious surveillance
program around the Indian Ocean pooling
and maximizing each country's assets to
fight illegal fishing at a regional
level the EU is convinced that the
future depends on our collective ability
to learn and adapt and find
collaborative solutions to global
challenges helping to make
sustainability and help the environment
the right and the responsibility of
everyone everywhere
[Music]